hip-hop artist Meek Mill is taking on
America's criminal justice system it's a
mission that he shared with us at the
table last year mill launched the reform
alliance in New York City yesterday and
he's getting some high star powered
support including from a fellow musician
that's jay-z and an NFL team owner
that's Robert Kraft the group says they
want to fix what they see as a broken
criminal justice system the Alliance
says millions of parolees are trapped by
harsh sentences for minor violations
like the one that sent McMeel to prison
back in 2017 well after his story gained
national attention Mills says he had no
choice but to be the face of a movement
that he hopes will bring people together
she not been on probation since the age
of 18 I'm 31 years old
musician meek Mill's voice is a familiar
sound in the hip-hop world but now he
wants to use it to change the criminal
justice system flanked by a group of
very high-profile supporters Mill
announced the launch of the reform
alliance every time I started to further
my life every year to was something that
always brought me back to Ground Zero
and those probation and I always wonder
what happened to the people that was in
situations worse than mine I'm here to
speak for the people who don't have a
voice in 2017 mill was sentenced to
serve two to four years in state prison
for a minor probation violation after a
decade old gun and drug possession
conviction after public protests and
legal appeals he was released after
serving five months I'm like one of the
lucky ones I never felt more powerless
than watching kids that I cared about
get outrageous sentences when I had gone
to Yale and seeing kids doing drugs at
Yale at worse they would get rehab and I
would see kids in the hood doing fewer
drugs getting 20 and 30-year sentences
according to the reform Alliance 4.5
million people like mill are currently
on parole or probation for unreasonable
terms their mission is to dramatically
reduce that number by changing laws and
policies this problem is so much bigger
than me
that fundamentally our criminal justice
system is just broken the alliance is
backed by a 50 million dollar pledge
from rap superstar jay-z and other
prominent figures including New England
Patriots owner Bob Kraft and
Philadelphia 76ers co-owner Michael
Rubin he was instrumental in Mills
release people always say to me how
lucky Mika's tapped me as his friend I
look at it exactly the opposite I
couldn't feel more fortunate to have
meek as one of my closest friends
because he's taught me so much about a
world I didn't understand at all I've
never been to jail before and going
there and seeing him I didn't sleep the
rest of the night we can make America
better if we really cure this problem
I'm from RC projects I'm from Brooklyn
and this has been a part of my life you
know if someone commits a crime they
should go to jail but these things are
just disproportionate and the whole
world knows it yeah and they are
thinking big listen they put together a
very high-powered group as you see Van
Jones is gonna be the CEO he's been
working on this for over 20 years he
said this started as a buddy movie and
now we are the Avengers mm-hm and that's
what they want to do they said there are
close to 5 million people who are living
under these you know what they call
harsh ridiculous rules and they hope to
reduce that by a million in the next
five years they are very serious about
this powerful line up is it was a terry
power from line up and every time
whenever anybody spoke it was even more
compelling one over the next over the
next it's been so hard to get changed in
so many different things but in this
instance of criminal justice these
ground-up movements have really changed
things gotten legislation to pass change
people's lives it's one place if you're
looking for hope you haven't changed
best I thought you know there were many
very powerful statements but he said
there are two Americas he said I had no
idea until I met Meek Mill and started
talking to Macmillan Meek Mill will tell
you well for us this is Thursday you
know this is a world we know but for
many people it was very eye-opening and
they had politicians and state attorney
generals in the office Josh Shapiro from
Pennsylvania was there who were also
working on this cause Donn's very
important I think change is on the way
with his I hope so